Wisconsin Michigan and Illinois are
under states of emergency giving
governor's the power to activate the
National Guard in advance of possibly
record-setting cold descending on the
north-central United States with cities
like Chicago said to be the epicenter of
this life-threatening weather event the
temperatures today are not and rather
today tomorrow and Thursday are not to
be taken lightly these are actually a
public health risk a particular risk in
this brutal cold is the homeless
population at a tent city just southwest
of Chicago's loop Gorge Oreo says he
will not take advantage of the homeless
shelters warming centers or even warming
buses the city is making available he
will stay in his tent winds that hold
the pocket of arctic air over the North
Pole have destabilized allowing the
supercooled air to slip south to the
United States the result temperatures
are predicted to drop in on the negative
20s wind accompanying the weather has
the potential to create wind chills
between negative 50 and 60 degrees
enough to cause frostbite to set in in a
matter of minutes it also puts
individuals at risk for even more
immediate life-threatening problems
nationwide more than 1,700 flights were
canceled 8,000 delayed due to the
weather when temperatures drop below
zero salt and chemicals that melt Road
ice are no longer effective so even
after plowing roads are expected to be
icy and dangerous road crews are
activated as far south as Georgia where
the weather is expected to reach also
where the Super Bowl is being played on
Sunday obviously is very important
because that a lot of people are going
to be in town this week we want to keep
them safe
Chicago is now under a windchill
advisory that will transition to a
warning by the end of this broadcast
meaning life-threatening conditions are
imminent the overnight lows will
threaten a record set back in 1985 of
negative 27 degrees the wind makes
things worse we don't get a break until
Thursday